wondering what to expect at Freddy
Fazbear's killer Pizzeria I've got you
covered we're going to have so much fun
together I'll be digging deep into not
only the lore of the Five Nights at
Freddy's video game but the lore of the
Creator exactly what's been going on
with all these delays okay and the
highly anticipated bite of 83 let's get
into it okay so we know the movie is
based on an indie video game that went
viral on YouTube Five Nights at Freddy's
Ford nights I knew that cuz was the
title but what exactly is the origin
story or lore if you will about The Man
Behind the game Scott cin is the brain
behind Five Nights at Freddy's but he
didn't actually start out with horror
far from it he got his start making
Christian video games called Pilgrims
Progress and the desolate hope which
critics say carried major anti-abortion
messages he's also so a major Republican
and donated like tons of money to Donald
Trump's campaign as well as the
Republican party in general after
Pilgrim's Progress and desolate hope he
shifted his Focus to familyfriendly
games like chipper and Sons Lumber
Company which was basically a wholesome
game about Woodland creatures chopping
wood or rather it was supposed to be
critics and fans found the Woodland
creatures to be a little bit creepy and
there was a lot of negative reviews
about it although the reviews did impact
Scott the com ments about the game were
exactly what inspired Five Nights at
Freddy's which brings us to Freddy
fazbears welcome to Freddy Fazbear's
pizzeria the game starts out pretty
simple you play Night Watch security at
a pizzeria nothing crazy except the
animatronics come to life at night to
brutally end whoever they come across
I'm not sure what the night watch
security salary is but I'm positive it's
not nearly enough for that we should be
looking at 1 million though the concept
is simple the story has since expanded
into a bunch of different directions
since there's been some lore shared
about fos bear's pizzeria used to be
this fun family-friendly place before
there were a bunch of random tragedies
connected to the franchise it was also
founded by William afon who owns the
robotics company yeah he's unfortunately
also a murderer he was trying to lure
five children in with the
family-friendly appeal only to brutally
end their lives and shove them into the
animatronic characters of the pizzeria
this place was huge in the ' 80s with
the kids they shut it down years ago the
owner is just not ready to let it go yet
no contract no peace now in this day and
age we're never shocked to hear about
delays in the film industry but there
were quite a bit on this project it's
clear that Five Nights at Freddy's is
Scott cn's baby which is why it's taking
so long to get the script finalized he's
the one who has the final say that tea
came straight from Jason Blum he
directly correlates Scott's
protectiveness over the film to the
Slowdown of production he says he
doesn't have the right to do anything
Scott doesn't like basically Scott has
this kind of like the equivalent of
Final Cut and it's taken longer than I
hoped to get the right story now there's
also been a revolving door of different
directors attached to this film as well
the most recent to leave was Chris
Columbus from the looks of it it seems
like the movie is going to incorporate
as much as they can from the first four
games of Five Nights at Freddy's which
includes a prequel to The Story the
final script they ended up going with
was co-written by Scott Seth cabac and
the director Emma Tammy now they
actually call that version of the script
the mic screenplay because the story
focuses on Josh Hutcherson's character
the protagonist of the first five games
Mike Schmidt riddled with guilt over a
tragedy in his past and now struggling
to take care of his younger sister on
his own Mike is low on options when he
lands a new job to pay the bills the
night security guard at Freddy Fazbear's
pizzeria it seems like it all starts out
good and fine like uh bring your sister
to work day I will work and you will
sleep I understand but then as these
things go there are ghost children
possessing giant
robots thanks for the heads up and these
giant possessed animatronics want Mike's
sister to join them something else that
seems like it's going to come straight
out of the video game the infamous
moment when one of the animatronics
characters bites someone by the name of
crying child resulting in major injuries
Wyatt Parker has been cast as young Mike
and posted on Instagram nice to see my
little brother again after it was
confirmed Lucas Grant was cast as
Garrett AKA crying child and it was
confirmed that the two would be playing
Brothers now the only time we ever see
young Mike in the game is for the bit of
83 so it's clear that we'll get to see
Mike work through his trauma either
through flashbacks or a portion of the
film dedicated to the prequel Five
Nights at Freddy's is the long awaited
horror film everyone is anticipating
this next spooky season regardless of
the very cringe conservative video games
as the predecessors Five Nights at
Freddy's was Like a Phoenix Rising From
the Ashes with hours of lore to work
from a script sculpted to Perfection and
Jason Blum behind it the bar could not
be
higher